Lisa tell decry the prevalence of
counseling in America in her new book
one nation under therapy this talk from
the American Enterprise Institute in
Washington DC less than our ten minutes
ladies and gentlemen welcome to AEI and
to this book forum in which we will be
hearing about a new book by AEI resident
scholars christina hoff sommers
and sally so tell the to our authors of
three of the most important and
controversial and widely noted books of
the last decade on important cultural
developments in America who stole
feminism in 1994 by christina hoff
sommers
identified and criticized the
metamorphosis of the modern feminist
movement from one pressing for equal
rights and opportunities for women to
one concerned with portraying women as
perpetual victims of a patriarchal power
structure for whom equality would never
be enough in 2000 Sally sue tel
published PC MD which identified the
surprising phenomenon of politically
correct medicine and charted its
penetration of Public Health nursing
mental health drug treatment and other
professions where the traditional task
of tending to the health and well-being
of individuals was being supplanted by a
larger and usually highly politicized
conceptions of social justice in 2001
hoff sommers book the war against boys
explored the effect the effects of
victim feminism in our schools and we
can now say was the first to identify
what is now a well-known and much
talked-about phenomenon of the lagging
performance of
boys in primary and secondary school in
one nation under therapy how the helping
culture is eroding self-reliance
Christina and Sally have joined forces
and also joined their backgrounds as
psychiatrist and philosopher to stunning
effect the book examines the culture of
therapy which they call therap ISM
something that replaces the ethical
language of right and wrong with the
medical psychological terminology of
disorders syndromes and conditions and
which sets itself against the
traditional American creed of
self-reliance fortitude and coping with
life's vicissitudes major and minor
through self-knowledge and the
institutions of family community and
faith the therapy culture sees
individuals as more or less helpless
victims in need of expertise often
pseudo expertise for it is not only a
culture they show but is also a industry
penetrating our schools businesses
government agencies and since September
11th are various tasks of emergency
response and preparedness this book
brings together the two authors
signature signature approaches of
meticulous research brilliant insight
and vigorous unflinching argument all of
it as I said to a wonderful effect it's
an important book it's just out and
we're delighted that they would begin
their book tour by discussing what they
have produced with us here at AEI with
that I'll turn it over to our authors
christina hoff sommers and sally Satele
ladies
good afternoon
I'm Christina summers in 2001 the Girl
Scouts of America introduced a
Stressless badge for girls eight to
eleven and according to a Girl Scout
badge book girls earn the award by
practice they can earn this award by
practicing focused breathing keeping a
feelings diary
they may also burn scented candles
listening to sounds of the rainforest or
even exchange foot massages all these
wastes will garner them points now
explaining the need for the Stressless
badge to the new york times a
psychologist for the Girl Scouts of
America she works at their research and
just Institute she explained that girls
are under a lot of duress these days now
you normally think of the Girl Scouts as
an organization that fosters
self-reliance and helps girls develop
camping skills and a good citizenship a
feelings diary I mean how does that
contribute to self-reliance I mean why
get a badge for that what where is the
merit there and it's self absorption
necessarily good for young people these
are the sorts of questions that we
consider in one nation under therapy we
evaluate this powerful therapeutic ethic
which we call therap ism this is an
ethic that valorizes openness emotional
self absorption the sharing of feelings
and the proponents of therap ism
sincerely believe that vulnerability
rather than strength characterizes the
American psyche they see their fellow
citizens especially children as
diffident somewhat anguished emotionally
apprehensive requiring a vast array of
therapists self-esteem counsellors
emotional intelligence coach coach's
traumatologist
to lead them through the stresses of
everyday life now it's a beguiling
philosophy because it appears to be kind
and sensitive but is it really in a
report called is repression adaptive a
team of psychologists studied a group of
high-school students whom they
categorized as in three types there
the repressors those are kids who
suppress unsettling thoughts and focused
more outside themselves there were the
repressors the sensitizers those were
children who were deeply aware of their
emotional states they would just throw
themselves into a feelings diary if
given the opportunity
you had the repressors the sensitizes in
the middle the intermediates the
students were then asked to evaluate
themselves and others using these
distinctions and so were the teachers
the repressors were rated more
successful academically socially by all
you know by the students and by the
teachers now of course this doesn't
establish a cause-and-effect
relationship between repression and
success but it does suggest that efforts
to turn healthy repressors into nervous
sensitizers could be injurious to them
now in another other there are other
questionable efforts to protect children
they're tender psyches school officials
and parents have now begun to challenge
the very idea of competition in the
schools and games where children keep
score school systems in places such as
Texas Maryland New York Virginia games
like dodgeball have been blacklisted one
education scholar said it's like Lord of
the Flies with adults encouraging it a
tag is under a cloud an elementary
school principal in Santa Monica
California expresses the new view of tag
it's a game in which there's a victim
and an it he said now Anthony Pellegrini
is a professor of early childhood
education at the University of Minnesota
and he's done some careful studies on
playground dynamics and we called him up
to see well is there any research on the
negative effects of tag and dodgeball
and he he told me that these are his
words he says this is ridiculous even
squirrels play tag that's a chase I
guess they don't play tag yeah he noted
the absence of any theoretical or
empirical basis for the new
protectiveness
and a question that we asked over and
over again in this book is what happened
to common sense isn't it obvious that
success in life depends on learning how
to cope with frustration failure
disappointment young people are not
helped by being pathologized they're not
improved by being wrapped in cotton wool
and deprived of the vigorous pastimes
and challenges they need for healthy
development but this new therapeutic
morality this therapeutic sensibility it
prevails not only in the playground but
also inside the classroom and here the
problem gets more serious now you may
have read recently I mean there's a
humorous side to that teachers are
hesitating to use red pens because
that's stressful for children to see any
indications of a harsh judgmentalism
and with some things marked wrong that
can make you feel bad about yourself one
New York tip a city teachers strongly
opposes red and he says and this is a
teacher of a veteran teacher of 25 years
my generation was brought up with the
idea of right and wrong and red was
always in your face and he says purple
is more gentle so they're yellow using
purple but in a recent book the language
police Diane Ravich the education
historian Diane Ravitch describes how
sensitivity and bias committees
routinely expunged from textbooks any
mention of anything that could be
potentially stressful to a child or
upsetting or distracting I mean if this
includes mention of tornadoes dangerous
animals even peanuts because that could
be upsetting to a child with allergies
now what is motivating all of this
hypersensitivity for the most part it is
grounded in a therapeutic concern for
the child's self-esteem the self-esteem
movement is still going strong it is
common in classrooms throughout the
country for children to do daily sort of
wonder of me exercises and I guess
losing it a game or getting an answer
wrong and having a red mark on your
paper can undermine this sense of wonder
now here's the problem
the connection between self-esteem and
good character trait
the connection between self-esteem and
academic achievement or life success
it's notoriously unclear no one has ever
been able to show a correlation and in
fact there's some evidence there I don't
want to say an inverse relation but I
will say that there are many fine men
and women of immense accomplishment who
are humble and self-deprecating and on
the other hand it is not uncommon for
burglars con artists even murderers to
have a very high view of themselves
everyone in charge of children I think
parents teachers educators they should
look at an article in the December 20th
issue of the Scientific American this of
2004 it's called exploding the
self-esteem myth and it's a decisive
refutation of this this myth about the
value of self esteem about the idea that
you can teach it that it's necessary it
shows that the concept is then
thoroughly discredited but of course I'm
not confident that science and and
realism is going to impress the
self-esteem enthusiasts building
self-esteem remains a central
educational goal in our schools for
example the study of American history
and low history in general but
specifically American history has been
radically transformed by the requirement
that school materials help children find
themselves and feel good about
themselves in too many classrooms the
primary emphasis is on feelings and
personal growth and validation the state
of California for example requires that
all instructional materials used in its
classroom quote contribute to a positive
educational experience for all students
but ok so far
I guess if they're for subjects
prospective textbooks to a social
content review is they call it to
determine whether or not they promote
individual development and self esteem
and quote they must instill in each
child a sense of pride in his or her
heritage and develop a feeling of
self-worth well because California is
one of the largest markets in the
country textbook publishers throughout I
mean they tailor their books for that
state
so most textbooks are written according
to California regulations and as Diane
Ravitch has abundantly shown these
sensitivity committees are everywhere
now and publishing but they these
educators publishers of textbooks and
tests educational materials they take
great care to avoid giving the
impression that the United States is in
any way exceptional or superior to other
societies because to single it out for
praise could hurt they think could hurt
children born in other countries
according to the special logic of the
sensitivity monitors monitors immigrant
children might feel diminished or
marginalized by reading a text that
extols the American tradition a
fact-based history curriculum that
highlights the founding doctrines the
great Wars the traditional heroes of
American history that might valorize
America they feel they could only do
this at the expense of other nations and
other cultures and that wouldn't be fair
and reassuring so well I should add at
this point that there is no evidence not
a scintilla of evidence that children or
their parents feel in any way diminished
by reading tests the texts or taking
tests that implied that our Democratic
traditions are good or that praise our
national heroes in fact what we do know
suggests the very opposite there was a
very fine study in 1998 by the public
agenda which is a bipartisan a survey
agency and they find that quote parents
of all demographic groups white black
Hispanic immigrant us-born clearly and
resoundingly want the schools to teach
children and this is a quote that the
National they want to teach children the
traditional ideals and stories of what
it means to be an American two-thirds of
them feel strongly that schools should
quote teach kids to be patriotic and
loyal toward the nation now until the
rise of therap ISM in our schools
history textbooks shown to students
celebrated our culture of Liberty most
if not all children took pride in the
heroes of the revolutionary and civil
wars and that prideful perspective and
was just taken for granted it is fast
becoming obsolete
today's textbooks writers and publishers
take great pains not to give students
the impression that there is anything
admirable or virtuous about the American
experiment now it is instructive in this
regard to look to see the contrast
between the way the educational
establishment reacted to the attack on
Pearl Harbor and to the way it reacts to
9/11 some 60 years later it's very
telling to compare them in 1945 therap
ISM as a mass phenomenon did not exist
several months after the Japanese bombed
Pearl Harbor in 1941 the National
Education Association published a slim
volume entitled quote the education of
freemen in American democracy
it was unabashedly patriotic it was
written by Columbia Teachers College
professor George s counts the book
discussed the role of teachers in the
war effort and as counts saw teachers
were the front line of defense in the
century-old battle against tyranny and
injustice their job was to imbue
students with the philosophical
understanding of the principles of
American democracy and to give them
pride in that tradition according to
counts students must be made fully
familiar with quote the long struggle to
liberate the human mind and civilize the
human heart and to that end he said the
public school should quote fashion and
education frankly and systematically
designed to give to the rising
generation the loyalties the knowledge
and the discipline of free men
so the loyalties the knowledge the
discipline of free men well fast-forward
to September 11th 2001 today's National
Education Association no longer
publishes books like the education of
free men in American democracy and
indeed the NEA s current policy and
educational philosophies is antithetical
to the idea that we should frankly and
systematically give the rising
generation the loyalties and knowledge
and discipline of free men on the first
anniversary of
the terrorist attack the NEA produced a
special 9/11 website advisory called
remember in September 11th they saw the
attack mainly in terms of the threat it
posed to children's mental health in one
typical lesson the guide suggests the
teachers quote have students draw a
picture of the tragic event using colors
they have chosen that represent the way
they feel high school students were
invited to join a circle of feelings
where they could quote discuss and
validate their feelings in a
non-judgmental discussion circle they
could also Sue's themselves with
recordings of rushing water and rustling
trees the current and EA no longer
viewed it mean they just didn't view it
as an occasion to do anything of the
sort that was done and just taken for
granted after Pearl Harbor it was an
opportunity for therapeutic healing and
self-discovery now the families and Work
Institute this is a nonprofit
organization that focuses on family
community in the work force and it
produced a curriculum called 9/11 as
history and according to its presidents
entire school systems in Dallas Texas in
Phoenix Arizona entire school systems
have used it the sponsors of this
curriculum could not be more mainstream
corporate supporters of the families and
Work Institute include General Electric
IBM Johnson & Johnson AT&T CNN's senior
correspondent Judy Woodruff and Pulitzer
prize-winning journalist novelist Anna
Quindlen they're on its board
philanthropies the red cross the
anti-defamation league they joined
together all these voices forces joined
together to produce a curriculum for
American children on the anniversary of
the terrorist attack and Bank One was
really active and put tremendous amount
of resources into this 9/11 s history
well the first lesson is called all
kinds of feelings and this was developed
by the anti-defamation league it's
intended for children K through
second-grade teachers suppose I supposed
to ask children a series of questions
including how do you do how would you
feel if someone knocked down a block
tower that you had just built and then
children as they give answers that
the teacher writes them on the board and
then these become the basis for a
feelings collage the collage in turn
serves as a catalyst for a class
feelings dance but this feelings drum
beat is unceasing after exploring their
feelings and learning how to be their
own heroes that's lesson two then they
can move on to lesson three what's
special about me
it's a self-esteem exercise everywhere
in this curriculum the children confront
this large vacuous happy face of
therapeutic pedagogy building strength
through knowledge that's the title of
lesson 10 this is developed for junior
high school kids now the title implies
that they're going to at least get some
information there's going to be some
knowledge building strength through
knowledge but rather than this was
created by a Department of Education at
the University of Oklahoma the well it's
the University of Oklahoma Health
Science Center a professor created it
and rather than giving students
knowledge about the worlds they get
knowledge about their own feelings quote
explained that you are going to be
discussing emotions and feelings the
teacher if the guide tells the teacher
and it affords the teacher that students
should recognize quote there are no
rights and wrongs when it comes to
feelings and opinions with few exception
this criticism has no intellectual
content
it's full of gimmicks amateur psychology
this is just one curriculum guide and
the NEA is another but if you dismiss
them as marginal or atypical
then you need to explain why on
September 11th with leading educators
school administrators philanthropists a
child development experts why would they
offer children something as banal as
9/11 is history I mean large numbers of
children doing this this pointless
exercise during the Second World War the
focus was not on validating feelings but
on teaching students about the moral
dimension of the struggle in which all
children and adults were engaged
American children badly need moral
clarity but our educational
establishment is just too uneasy with
the idea of moral
judgment and too carried away with
therap ISM to meet this elementary need
now there are many who believe that
therap ISM it in the schools is benign
it's constructive it comforts children
it calms their fears it enhances their
feelings of self-acceptance the evidence
however does not bear this out on the
contrary the therapeutic regime
pathologize --is healthy young people it
encourages remedial measures for
non-existent vulnerabilities it wastes
students time it impedes their moral
development American students are with
few exceptions mentally and emotionally
sound they are resilient they could cope
with dodgeball it's important to notice
that those who practice therap ISM are
working hard to change the American
character to change our national
character from the earliest day of its
founding the nation was guided by a
philosophy that social historian
historians call the American creed and
it's paramount values we're self-reliant
stoicism courage in the face of
adversity valorisation of excellence
therap ism is at odds with them all and
before inflicting any more argot on
children i think there should be a
national discussion on the strengths and
weaknesses of the therapeutic ethic our
book one nation under therapy is Sally
in my humble contribution to this cause
now my talk has focused on children
Sally will folks Ally's will focus on
the effects of therapies among adults
after she finishes we'll take questions
and if time allows and we muck we'll
maybe there'll be time to lead the
audience through a feeling stance that
would be a first at AEI Sally thank you
Christina
as Christina showed the seemingly
compassionate philosophy of therap ISM
is often the very antithesis of
compassion it's led to policies and
practices in children that that weekend
they don't strengthen them and the time
I have with you today I want to talk
about how therap ism how it's been
detrimental to adults and first I'm
going to take a very recent example a
very tragic example that actually
involved exporting therap ISM overseas
specifically to South Asia the site of
the recent tsunami and then I'll come
back to the US when the tsunami struck
of course the inclination of mental
health professionals in fact everyone
was to help but it turned out that there
was considerable considerable
disagreement over the kind of
psychological first aid that the victims
needed representing one view was a Sri
Lankan psychiatrist named dr. garrison
in fact he was the only psychiatrist for
the entire eastern seaboard of sri lanka
about 1.3 million people after the giant
waves hit he was busy coordinating
foreign aid distributing medicine
transporting corpses in his pickup truck
but what he wasn't doing was therapy as
he told The Washington Post reporter to
talk about psychological needs when
you've got thousands of people using one
toilet in a refugee camp that's absurd
he specifically discouraged
international aids aid groups from
sending counselors actually as did other
Sri Lankan officials and he certainly
did not think that Sri Lankan children
needed to be doing art therapy but
that's exactly what a psychologist
thousands of miles away and sells very
Maryland thought they needed this
well-meaning soul who doubtless
disapproved of dodgeball dropped
everything a few days after Christmas
and flew out to gali Sri Lanka he told
The Washington Post also in a different
article psychological scarring needs to
be dealt with as quickly as possible he
warned the longer we wait
the more danger one of his solutions was
to take a page from the feelings
curriculum that Christina told you about
and transport it to the third world to
the children of golly sri lanka this
psychologist wanted to hand out coloring
books and crayons on a mass scale so
they could draw their psychic pain well
so what happened when the feelings
paradigm was introduced to the
devastated children well according to an
American reporter who shadowed the
psychologist on his visit the kids were
pretty bewildered they didn't engage you
can almost imagine what what was going
through their their minds when the
translator told them that the coloring
books were to help them explore their
feelings and and share them through
drawing I mean was this nice
psychologist here to bring us clean
water or help us rebuild our houses or
maybe help me find my parents I mean no
wonder they were a bit confused well
some mischievous colleagues of mine had
given a name to this practice they call
it trauma tourism forget one nation
under therapy we are talking one planet
under therapy and that's what these
trauma tourists are counselors well
intended though they may be seem to want
and fortunately their good intentions
often do not take into account the
native healing systems of the lands to
which they they go the actual needs and
wants of the victims and they wrongly
assume that their so-called clients
share Western ideas about confronting
grief and it's not just victims of
natural disasters who yearn for
practical help as we described in one
nation under therapies we have a whole
section on this called exporting PTSD
post-traumatic stress disorder
there was a refugee camp in Fort Dix New
Jersey for Albanian Kosovars who
certainly endured horrible devastating
losses during the Balkan war and there
were mental health professionals at this
refugee camp planning to do group
therapy and individual therapy with them
the
the plan was that these patients
supposed patients would tell their
trauma stories and the therapist would
listen and they would process the grief
and this would help the patients or the
the refugees cope well it turned out
these refugees had no interest in being
patients they certainly wanted to tell
their story and they did and who they
wanted to tell their trauma stories to
was Amnesty International and the war
crimes investigators from the State
Department now to downplay the need for
professional therapy as I am doing in no
way diminishes the suffering in these
places we don't deny for a second the
sea of misery that surrounds doctor gana
Sina Sri Lanka or the relocated Balkan
refugees but the help they need and want
rarely comes from outsiders barring
therapy mental well-being comes from
safety a glimpse of the future an
opportunity to be productive of course
people seek comfort and they often want
to talk but it is the bedrock
institutions and relationships already
in existence their families their
churches their communities their healers
those are the people and the and the
entities that they will instinctively
turn to in times of uncertainty and
immense sorrow and this is a universal
habit in fact in one nation under
therapy we question whether trauma
counseling even makes sense for
Americans let alone for Sri Lankan
children and war-torn Balkan refugees
yet these trauma counselors have become
a fixture on the landscape of disaster
in this country as you all know I'm sure
after 9/11 legions of counselors were
deployed in New York City the Federal
Emergency Management Agency gave a
hundred and fifty million dollars for
counseling a lot of it ended up being
unused and the New York State Office of
mental health had estimated that one in
four two million New Yorkers would need
counseling
psychiatrists predicted an epidemic of
post-traumatic stress disorder
sure you know post-traumatic
stress disorder it's it's a serious
debilitating mental illness it's marked
by insistent painful memories often
terrible nightmares crippling anxiety
and fearfulness it can be a very serious
and debilitating condition there's no
question about that but that's not what
most New Yorkers were suffering from
they were suffering from normal rational
distress and what was so striking to us
was the scale of the miscalculation on
the part of mental health professionals
in fact as one chapter is titled
September 11th the mental health crisis
that wasn't in that chapter we have
enormous amount of data documenting this
I'll very quickly tell you that major
surveys done by the federal substance
abuse management and mental health
services administration by the New York
Academy of Medicine by the VA
incidentally the VA expected great
psychological fallout from this they
thought that veterans who had been
traumatized in the Vietnam War that that
the terrorist attacks would rekindle
their their distress and they would
flock to the VA but that didn't happen
were people using Valium rizzo loft on a
mass scale again assessment by a
pharmaceutical industry analysts found
that after September 11th I have to
admit I was a little surprised at this
there was barely a blip in the
prescriptions for new antidepressants
and and sleeping pills and finally of
course a number of surveys had asked
about problems with sleep and
concentration and poor memory and
anxiety
excuse me troubling memories poor
concentration and anxiety and found no
surprise in increase after September
11th hiring people who live closer to
Ground Zero than the rest of New York
City and higher in New York City than
the rest of the country but over time
these levels within six months gradually
returned to pre 9/11 levels did some
people develop post-traumatic stress
disorder well of course of course they
did we can't know
from these surveys because they were not
done with enough diagnostic sensitivity
for us to make that diagnosis but
clearly as in as in every kind of
disastrous situation people whose lives
were threatened and who sustained
significant losses are going to be the
ones that highest risk but even then
there's it is not a hundred percent
development of this condition between 30
and and ten percent of people tend to
develop post-traumatic stress disorder
after an intense sudden life-threatening
event and in the majority of cases it
resolves within the year so in the end
there was no epidemic of post traumatic
stress disorder but there was an
epidemic of media stories quoting
frantic mental health professionals
saying that there would be one what we
heard much less about however were
important lessons from the field of
disaster psychology which has been
studying human response to calamity for
decades and I'm referring here to the
evidence indicating that the way people
cope is influenced largely by two
important mechanisms the first is the
meaning they make out of their
experience essentially do they
categorize it psychologically as a loss
or a threat or possibly a challenge and
the second mechanism is their perception
of themselves are they confident agents
can they resolve their problems solve
problems can they manage their emotional
states are they resourceful these kinds
of these kinds of self perceptions now
we all know that these kinds of self
images are products of many things one's
temperament one's intelligence also
one's previous experience and one's
history of having handled traumatic
experiences in the past but they could
also be influenced by other people and
by the culture one is in
the friends for this is power of
suggestion now that's not an especially
technical term I know but it's a
potentially powerful phenomenon
especially for a person in a vulnerable
period let's say after a disaster
physical assault or combat if for
example a person is told to expect to
experience symptoms sleep problems
agitation and so on
he will pay special attention to them if
he has not told that such symptoms are
generally part of a normal stress
reaction and will fade over time as they
typically do but is instead warned that
they are a foreboding of some dread
post-traumatic stress disorder a message
that trauma counselors often give to
victims and in fact how they justify
their administration's well this
practically invites people to interpret
their normal emotional and physical
sensations after an ordeal as a
pathological event now this is a
potentially big problem because people
who think of themselves as passive and
helpless and sick will often act that
way in recognition of this basic mental
dynamic of suggestion actually the
British Army in World War one went so
far as to ban the very term
shell-shocked this was an effort to make
the condition seem less medical and to
keep soldiers from viewing themselves as
psychiatric casualties now don't worry
I'm not suggesting we banned the term
PTSD clearly we need to diagnose people
who are afflicted and and treat them
efficiently as possible but I am saying
that we have some lessons to learn about
how to work with men and women who have
been to the intensity of war and I'm
thinking in particular about the lessons
that we should have learned from Vietnam
briefly in the 70s and 80s many mental
health professionals especially those
associated with VA hospitals and clinics
inadvertently set the conditions for
sizeable numbers of Vietnam veterans to
think of themselves as psychologically
damaged not changed as would most people
be after harrowing and intense
experiences but damaged the first
problem here was essentially a
diagnostic fashion of the 70s and 80s
which was to assume that PTSD would
develop in almost all veterans after
combat that this was a normative
experience and that such PTSD could be
chronic so right away this set up the
expectation for illness then second the
treating clinicians inadvertently
reinforced the veterans identity as a
psychiatric casualty through treatment
that included immersion in group therapy
that where the veterans talked
incessantly about war stories they use
psychotherapy emphasizing the confession
of survivor guilt and often inpatient
hospital stays of several months
duration which severed connection from
the outside world making readjustment to
civilian life harder while making
identification with the realm of invalid
ISM even stronger and third add to this
the fact that veterans could get
disability payments then are actually
fairly generous between two and twenty
five hundred dollars a month now some of
these men and women clearly needed the
disability money they couldn't work and
and that was fine they certainly
deserved it but for others the payments
created an a perverse incentive to
remain dysfunctional I'm gonna get back
to that in a moment but let me hasten to
say I'm not saying that there is no
place for a veteran who's coming to
terms with his war experience not to
talk about nightmares if he has them and
not to talk about his regrets or
recriminations if he has that I'm done
and what I'm I am NOT saying that what
I'm saying is that the repeated telling
of terrifying or demoralizing stories is
a bad idea for people trying to readjust
to civilian life
in fact some number of the men I knew
when I worked at the West Haven VA
hospital in the late 80s and 90s men who
became sadly chronic PTSD patients
probably could have been rehabilitated
if several conditions had been met for
example if they were given a different
narrative if they were told that their
distress was temporary
if the efforts to help them were
practical based on employment and their
economic security and their family
relationships which almost inevitably
would would almost fray when someone is
away from home so long at the very least
if the treatments that they were given
did not physically isolate themselves
from society and enhance aggression I
think a number of them wouldn't have
become chronic PTSD patients and if
disability were time limited for some of
them and not chronic a colleague of mine
wrote an article in Public Interest
awhile ago called at the VA it pays to
be sick and and sadly I think it does
well let's fast forward to today some of
the news accounts we've been reading
about Iraq vets predict this essentially
Vietnam all over again I'm sure you've
seen them they say 30 you know we'll
probably be seeing 30% of Iraq veterans
suffering from post-traumatic stress
they mentioned 30% because that's the
number assigned to Vietnam vets and it's
a number we dispute in the in the book I
don't have time to get into that now
they conjure up images again of these
walking the stereotypical walking time
bomb the the Rambo the taxi driver but
in my view these news stories are
reckless and irresponsible yes some
soldiers will get PTSD and fortunately
there's good treatment for it and many
need and deserve of course from the
Department of Defense and the VA as
practical assistance reintegrating into
civilian life morbid predictions of the
vast number of Iraq vets who will have a
future of dysfunction ahead of them is
demoralizing and risks fulfilling a
prophecy that I don't believe personally
will come true in summing up then this
brings us back to one of the basic
messages of one nation under therapy to
reaffirm that vast majority of human
beings are resilient that debilitating
stress is not the most common reaction
to traumatic events actually appears
that it appears that the most salient
and enduring effect of a life shattering
experience is actually growth it's
called in fact post-traumatic growth
that's what psychologists have have
called it the helpers that offer their
services after the tsunami and September
11th and our veterans certainly toil in
good faith but they also endorsed one of
the mistaken notions of therap ISM which
is that people are fragile and in their
zeal to help
they have underestimated our natural
fortitude Thank You Christine and Sally
thank you very much we're going to go to
questions I believe that's acceptable to
our panelists is that right you'll take
questions from the audience and a mic
will be going around please wait till
you get to mic I want to begin with a
question of my own when I was discussing
this book with you when you were first
writing it my first reaction was how
important is this phenomenon aren't we
talking about some marginal groups books
thinkers the book makes a powerful case
that the therapy movement is anything
but marginal it's powerful it's in the
school bureaucracies it's in the
textbooks it's in large business
corporations the Bush administration is
spending hundreds of millions of dollars
it is it is a big and important
phenomenon that you discuss and dissect
so now my question is the opposite where
are the forces of of reaction where the
forces that are of common sense that are
going to set things straight why is this
movement so powerful
maybe it's because as Sally suggests
that there are systems that pay people
to malinger maybe it is because many
parents find the banning of competition
from schools are reassuring maybe in
some sense it is popular but in your
book you suggest that there is a counter
culture in America that of traditional
self-reliance and fortitude and I wonder
what you think the future of the contest
between the cultures of therap ISM and
the culture of self-reliance is going to
be well I will first say that there are
differences of opinions in the schools
for example a lot of it is driven by
parents parents want to protect jr. from
adversity from feeling bad we tell the
story of a coach in New Orleans coach
Fitz who was a beloved but sort of hard
driving very demanding disciplinarian
and he was he's beloved he was made the
making of many a young man and they had
come back after graduating to honor him
they wanted to build a new gym or
something to honor coach Fitz at the
same time they were trying to honor him
another group of parents younger of
young students we're trying to get him
fired because they thought he was too
harsh too demanding and too much of a
disciplinarian so we're going to have
this tug-of-war and what we wanted to
warn people in this book is to be aware
that it's going on to become acquainted
with the arguments for and against which
we tried to present in one nation under
therapy and that before we fundamentally
change the character of the nation the
the
the direction of the nation there ought
to be a national discussion of some kind
so we put it forward in this book
because too much of it is happening
behind the scenes
some of it is driven by teachers some of
it school administrators in the area
that I looked at in the schools but a
lot of it is simply happening at without
any organized opposition so we would
like to see some reaction and some
wording of these efforts but do did you
want to add anything yes
to what degree is the outbreak of all
these exotic and higher salinities
I can repeat the question okay okay to
what degree is the outbreak of all these
exotic learning disabilities in schools
due to government subsidies for those
same disabilities I guess I don't quite
understand how the government subsidizes
those disabilities what could be a
little or you do you mean getting extra
time on the SAT if you have attention
deficit disorder thank you I'll give you
a real good one
this was actually said to me when my
stepson was giving the usual
disciplinary problems a friend helpfully
said you need to get him professionally
diagnosed it for an ADHD so the school
can pay for his counseling oh yeah well
there's an epidemic of attention deficit
hyperactivity disorder one psychologist
said that if Tom Sawyer and Huck Finn
were around today they'd be diagnosed
with a DD and given ritalin Sally and I
aren't against psychotropic drugs were
not against free mm and we believe the
hyperactivity is a serious disability
disorder but it this drugs are way over
prescribed far too many children are
diagnosed mostly boys and young you're
quite right it is subsidized and there
are all sorts of Sally said perverse
incentives for children to get their
child a diagnosis yes I don't I haven't
quantified it so I don't know the extent
to which it is disrupting the system but
you read about it a lot so it's I think
it's probably significant can't can't
expand further than that though there
you know but DC used a lot of its
homeland security money not a lot but
you know several million dollars to fund
there's these little booklets called
masters of disasters which is basically
for schoolteacher to help kids cope with
the idea of death and you know trauma
and so I don't know whether but I have a
lot of you know literature on that topic
if you want it we'd like to see that
the other thing is that when you were
talking about what's done in the school
it actually ring a bell of what's going
on in you know when you go to the park
with your kids and you talk to the
parents and when you talk about Charl
rearing and they say no no no no it's
parenting what we're doing is parenting
we're and it's like it's see that
there's this tradition now that you know
you're not supposed as a parents to ever
say no to your kids or if you do you
have to you know be on your knees look
at them and Pat them and say this is not
good what you're doing do you understand
mommy and when I was kind of you know
raised in Europe and that's probably one
of the few good things left in Europe is
that you can say no and if you don't
even have to provide an explanation and
so it seemed that those two things are
really related and I mean again we have
many examples of this in the book and
for example there's a group of parents
in Massachusetts they decided that the
children in Italy in their their
community or too overwhelmed by losing
it baseball so they they have no score
baseball but then they found children
were still upset striking out so they
had a no strikeout rule Johnny could
stay up to bat until he hit the ball
well tired parents discovered the games
would go on and on and on so they had to
change the rule so and again not all
parents were asking for it but there's a
small group of hyper protective
therapeutically obsessed parents who are
demanding these things and I think other
parents have to give to the conversation
and the second thing you mentioned
Europeans we compare in the book some
classroom practices of Italian teachers
into Chinese teachers and American
teachers and one amusing example to us
is a some Italian teacher saw a tape of
an American classroom where a boy is
doing a problem and it gets it exactly
wrong and the teacher says very good
however here's another way to see it and
then she gives the right answer and
they're laughing hysterically in Italy
and China and here they show it and no
one laughs because that's that's right
you're supposed to create an affirmative
where the child feels good about wrong
answers and the Syrian we laugh at this
but the serious point is our kids are
not going to be able to compete in a
global economy if we can't learn math
and science and we can't compete on a
level that they are achieving in Europe
and in Asia and we're we're behind at
but we're burdened with the with
therapists their schools are relatively
free of that they have other problems
but they don't have therapist i yes i
want to remark on actually your
introductory comment about homeland
security which is a positive development
with chris asked before there any
resistance to some of this I should say
and I know Homeland Security is very
interested in they're interested in the
psychological sequelae of terrorism and
also what I call pre TSD in other words
the anticipatory anxiety about potential
attacks and there has and put out some
good documents and also in the last few
years there's been a nice critical mass
of Studies on something called
debriefing and debriefing really is the
centerpiece of what trauma therapists do
very briefly it's a counselor sitting
with a group of people who've been
through some frightening experience in
which they're they're exhorted to talk
about how terrifying it was how
horrified they were and this is supposed
to actually prevent PTSD this this group
therapy goes on for about two to four
hours well it turns out there have been
a number of actually randomized control
clinical trials and they've found that
people who are subject to this
debriefing intervention after some kind
of awful event and this actually was
usually terrible car accidents or burn
accidents that they took longer to
recover emotionally so in most cases the
intervention was an earth didn't matter
just a waste of money but in some cases
it actually clinically impeded recovery
so the World Health Organization the
National Health Service in Britain our
National Institute of Mental Health and
the Red Cross have actually now
actively discouraged debriefing and
that's a that's encouraging Sally you
mentioned that how the practitioners of
therap ISM have under underestimated our
national fortitude
I wonder however if they're not right on
the money with their own degree of
fortitude and I wonder whether the two
of you have thought about since you're
such concise thinkers have you thought
about nailing the dichotomy between
liberals and conservatives as far as
that split tends to go the strength
versus weak please forgive me the
Liberals in the room but I'd also like
to know I my feeling is is that Emerson
might was most probably a liberal on the
Left what do you think he would have
thought about the concept of
self-reliance and the way it's been oh I
thought destroyed today Emerson has
always been claimed as a conservative
philosopher but yeah I don't know that
it breaks down easily between liberal
and conservative though there are some
obviously a lot of these are promoted by
the sort of touchy-feely liberalism but
you find therapist um in some of our
churches a conservative and liberal
churches there's this it's a kind of a
national obsession to this what we call
emotivism this Republic of feelings
someone said you're just sharing and
this compulsion to tell all that's not
necessarily political but do you see it
as
yes I think philosophically you will
find that war associated with
conservative tradition would be stoicism
self-reliance but we really see it as
sort of having more to do with American
exceptionalism that historians liberal
and conservative I mean Marty lips it
would be the classic example of a
liberal historian are certainly a
moderate political moderate who he's
written written at length about what
makes American unusual and how did this
country how did we create such a dynamic
and successful vibrant society in
relatively short time and they look to
this individualism discouraged this
can-do attitude problem-solving and
patriotism I mean you can't think that
that would be something liberals would
oppose conservatives certainly don't
oppose it but what we find is that it's
a small group sort of accountable to no
one and they're working against this
Creed against the exceptionalism they
want to impose something else and
largely in our schools of education and
in the helping professions and as I said
it's it needs to be questioned and our
hope is to convert convince people in
both blue states and red states although
what the book will probably resonate
very very well in the red states
and strong men of action or whatever but
you had things like The Promise Keepers
which was a conservative movement of men
in a stadiums crying and learning to get
them to you know catch them so far I
mean I'm not opposed to it entirely but
you know you can't just put this on
liberals conservatives have gone some
distance Christina says there's no clean
typology but they and we don't even
mention the words liberal or
conservative in the book at all but I do
think it's fair to say that there is a
general axis of temperament which goes
from nurture to discipline and that's
left and that's right and you do see
that in the mental health professional
profession in general probably helping
professions in general do tend to select
for people with left-of-center political
affiliation so that's just
well-documented another social
institution that at that of the church
and a religious area do you find that
the churches are starting to give give
ground if you will to the concepts of
therap ISM and that by doing so they're
actually contributing to it but we
didn't write that much about the
churches except that we looked at the of
a chapter called sin to syndrome and we
were interested in how the language of
vice and virtue was changed into the
language of syndrome and might you know
don't blame me blame my condition and we
looked at the Catholic Church and how
for so many years these priests the that
were molesting children how did the
church deal with them they they've
become much better obviously but in the
70s and throughout the 70s and early
80's the the church sort of gave over it
was won over to psychobabble and sent
priests for counseling we now know that
a child abuser cannot be cured they have
to be kept away from children completely
they're not should never be put back and
once they've
and act like that but what happened was
the church would put them back with
children and believed the therapists so
even the and yet we wondered how could
it such a traditional organization as
the Catholic Church have been carried
away with some very indeed very silly
therapies so no institution is immune
from this this ideology yes sorry let me
let me take the thought here beyond
self-reliance there's been a argument
going on for three or four decades I
guess that the so-called the talking
cure doesn't work what do you say if
someone says you know I go to a
psychiatrist or a psychotherapist or
there's all those names and I feel
better when I can talk out my problems
with somebody it's not no no no we're
not against that at all I am a therapist
she does it all the time
normal everybody has problems relatively
normal people it helps me oh then we
have I was absolutely nothing against
that it's that way we have a chapter
called emotional correctness and what we
do criticize though is imposing certain
certain notions of how people should
react to adversity react to grief react
to loss that they should somehow as the
phrase goes heal it to feel it to heal
it or talk it out all we're saying is
that for many people if that is not
their natural style that they shouldn't
go out of their way to force themselves
or allow people to coerce them to be
more emotive to to speak more volume
about their interstates
if that's not their natural style and we
do shall we in fact I think the virtue
of this book is that it's it's really
quite empirical is that is that
reticence and distraction actually can
be extremely healthy for people who are
in distress on the other hand discussing
one's problems with an expert it can be
enormous ly helpful cognitive behavioral
therapy is well known to be effective
usually short term therapies where a
person comes in with a prescribed
problem end up being the most effective
but frankly if you wanted to pay you
know $200 a day four days a week and lay
on a couch in an analyst office I
wouldn't be opposed to that I'd want you
to pay for it though I just finished
reading Norton had lers book called the
last well person and he I could see a
lot of parallels between what he is
saying and what you what you've been
saying here and what your book addresses
namely that I don't think he uses this
term but it's almost unavoidable there
is a sort of a medical industrial
complex where the more therapy we seek
the more medical care we seek the more
pharmaceuticals we take the more of
these things we indulge in we're
basically supporting this industry now
that is a difficult hurdle I think to
overcome I certainly agreed with his
point I wonder what you think about it
I'll say something that I'm sure Sally
will have a response well we're trying
to argue in one nation under therapy is
that a lot of these therapeutic
innovations or it were very well
intentioned by people who want to be
kind understanding gentle and helpful if
we thought it worked
we wouldn't have written this book if we
thought that the self esteem programs
the compassion pedagogy the grief
counselors the trauma if we thought this
was making us stronger our kids better
then we would be
you know celebrating it but what we find
over and over again when we try to find
the data when we look for evidence
where is it working doesn't help our
people stronger are they happier we
couldn't find it what we found was that
there were people some people were just
self deceived in thinking that without
any evidence that they that these
programs were were positive and this is
a call to arms to parents to citizens to
ask for some accountability and to ask
do we want to continue going down this
path where the tendency is to turn the
human condition into a pathology so
we're simply thinking we shouldn't
medicalize the human experience that's
the method message of this book
Oh
well I suppose I should introduce the
question by saying if it doesn't work
really why does it matter but I mean
Mike I guess Mike the substance of the
question would be I can see how sort of
philosophically therap ism is at
variance with some of them most sort of
distinctive features of America
I wondered if there'd been any if you'd
found any evidence which suggests that
people who to undergone therapy did have
attitudes that were unusual from the
American point of view in other words
what we know are they less
individualistic of a you know less
patriotic of a less Americans are off
the scale when it comes to the question
you know do you consider your life is
what under your control compare with
every other part of the world are they
not off the scale as it were are they do
they tend to be more sort of fatalistic
in the way that Europeans are well two
points people active I've observed
people in therapy if you're talking
about sustain talk therapy if anything
there be less communitarian and a lot
more self-absorbed and narcissistic but
I should add before Christina comments
that the book is is not about therapy
per se it's about the migration of the
the tenets of sort of the therapeutic
ethic into other corners of American
life and and that's again where we worry
that that some damage is done a lot of
these principles make a lot of sense in
the therapeutic setting but not when
they're brought into schools and other
institutions yeah that's what I was
going to say is it we're not against
people getting help if they are
genuinely in under psychic duress but
the average child is not under psychic
duress dodgeball does not create a
mental health incident children should
not be treated as if they are fragile it
will shatter in a thousand pieces if
they're made of spun glass and what
we're looking to see is that just the
effects on children that can
what will they do if they've been
wrapped in cotton wool and had almost no
experience with failure or setback how
prepared are they to go into the world
and we know that our educational system
is insufficiently
rigorous not challenged challenging them
based on a faulty falak well we've
believed a faulty philosophy we're very
concerned that out of a completely
misguided notion about self-esteem is
that we're withholding basic teachings
about our city our nation and our
traditions which the students should be
aware of and yes take pride in as every
generation of Jeff child has done we're
not of course supporting some mindless
jingoism but simple basic understanding
of the traditions and they in the heroes
of American society so again as Sally
said we're we're very worried about not
so much what goes on in therapy which is
sometimes problematic but we didn't
address that we're worried about
treating treating normal human beings
and everyday life as if it were a
therapeutic setting
okay I would one last all right one last
one or maybe yes
so the act the concept of adversity
builds character the concept of
adversity building character is really
what's it certainly being challenged
here would you agree and and I'd say
that if you if you looked at the
populace and thought about their
philosophies you might find just my own
personal point of view you might find
that that those people who who believe
in strength and and in endurance and and
saying no and they believe they do not
believe in moral relativism those are
the kinds of people who probably would
be in favor of tag and dodgeball and
saying no to their children maybe even
god forbid spanking their children if
they did something horrendous but
there's a group and I just happen to
feel that a lot of them are probably on
the Left what we will say a lot of
immersion schools of Education as I
looked at the aware of these ideas who's
dreaming up who they're we talked about
a book in which the author is against
the ideology of achievement but she
thinks that's just very distressful for
children that they're captive to an
ideology of achievement and we find this
so unfortunate because there's a small
group of American students the very
high-performing kids who are competing
for select positions in elite schools
they are very good at this idea ideology
of achievement nothing holds them back
if you don't you know they don't care if
they win at dodgeball but they do care
if they get very high scores on tests
and they are master competitors but the
average student is not in that group
vast numbers of American kids about a
third don't go to college at all the
others are going to schools that will
take that are not competitive and we
looked at those kids and what is the
effect on them and their aspirations
within a in an educational setting where
they're discouraged from having this
so-called ideal ideology of achievement
and it's harmful and again we just wish
that these were the views that are very
much part of the curriculum but
informing the curriculum the philosophy
that more parents knew about it
and could have a say on what's going on
because we do believe it's quite harmful
yes thank you very much for coming
Christina Hoff Sommers is author of the
war against boys and who stole feminism
Sally Satele is a practicing
psychiatrist a lecturer at Yale
University's School of Medicine one
nation under therapy is published by st.
Martin's Press